foreign
minister
t-shock
Chancellor Clinton
president Michelle
distinguished guests ladies and
gentlemen
dear friends
allow me first of all to thank Queen's
University of Belfast and youth
secretary Clinton for this incredible
event
it is an opportunity to thank
and praise the architects of the Good
Friday Belfast agreement
but also to look at our
friendship
between the United Kingdom and the
European Union and most importantly
to look at the future of peace
in Northern Ireland
allow me to begin with a personal memory
in my twenties I studied in London
I fell in love with this vibrant and
vital City colorful and cosmopolitan
it was in the late 1970s
and a few years earlier the women's
peace movement in Northern Ireland had
won the Nobel Peace Prize
but the Hope inspired by that
recognition
had largely epped away
so during my time in London
when I heard about Northern Ireland in
the news
it was a story of conflict
of bombs and violence in the streets
today my children are in their twenties
and they have learned a completely
different story
a story of reconciliation at Hope
a story of economic and social progress
for young Europeans
Northern Ireland is today a cool place
it's a place of Music film sets and
stunning landscapes
this brighter reality is only possible
because on Good Friday
25 years ago
the leaders and the people of Northern
Ireland
decided to plant a seed
in soil previously stained with Blood
and Tears
and it is the seed of peace and
possibility for new generations
which has been growing defiantly ever
since
today we pay tribute to all those who
planted that seed
we thank the Visionary leaders of all
communities
in Northern Ireland
the United Kingdom and Ireland
who believed that
while history shapes people
can also shape history
and this is what happened ever since
the people of Northern Ireland
have shaped a new history
of course Decades of troubles are
impossible to forget
the past cannot be re-written
but writing a new present and future
is always a possibility
and that is exactly what the people of
Northern Ireland have decided to focus
on
being the master of your destiny
it is in this mindset
that my first meeting with prime
minister sunak took place
it was at the United Nations climate
conference in Egypt
at the end of last year
and since that first meeting
we agreed to focus on the road ahead
more than on past disagreements
because the challenges ahead of us are
daunting
for the first time in decades
large-scale war is back in Europe
the foundations of peaceful coexistence
in our continent have come under attack
and This concerns all Europeans not only
Russia's closest Neighbors
the European Union
and the United Kingdom are in this
together
we both want to uphold Ukraine's
sovereignty and territorial integrity
we both want Russia's aggression to fail
and we both want to restore a just peace
in Europe
we still see the world with the same
eyes
we still share the same values and sense
of purpose
we still believe that peace is precious
and can never be taken for granted
and I'm particularly grateful to our
British friends
not only for their unwavering support
for Ukraine and European security
but also for the determination
on that occasion and ever since
to overcome our differences and find
workable solutions to the challenges
that arose after brexit
The Windsor framework is a new beginning
for Old Friends
it turns the page
on years of division and dispute
it is an opportunity to set our sights
on the future of our partnership
and to focus on what brings us together
as President Biden said last week
the dividends of Peace are all around us
Northern Ireland's GDP has more than
doubled since 1998.
and could increase by a further 50
percent
over the next decade
new private Investments are driving
activities like fintech and cyber
security
and more investors are now eyeing at
Northern Ireland this is a unique
opportunity for Northern Ireland
there is so much we can do together
with wisdom and vision
the same wisdom and vision that the
leaders of Northern Ireland have already
shown over the past 25 years
there are so many that deserve special
recognition
like John Hume
and David tremble
who were key
to reaching an agreement
allow me to refer to one example to
someone who 25 years ago did not agree
with the text of the Good Friday Belfast
agreement
I'm talking about the Reverend Ayan
Paisley
yet
less than 10 years after that Good
Friday
Ian Pacey became Northern Ireland's
first minister
working under the Saint Andrews power
sharing structures
and working with a deputy first Minister
Martin McGinnis
who used to be one of his staunchest
foes
this is one of the Miracles
of the Good Friday Belfast agreement
and the journey of Ian Paisley mirrors
the Journey of thousands of people on
this island
history now calls on today's leaders to
embark on a similar path
and to shape together the future of
Northern Ireland
ladies and gentlemen the future of
Northern Ireland belongs to its people
only you
can make the seed of the Good Friday
Belfast agreement
continue to grow
and to flourish
only you
can take the next step
on the path of prosperity
and possibility
and let me borrow the words of a woman
from Northern Ireland
called Anne Patterson
she gave birth to a baby girl just
minutes after the Good Friday Belfast
agreement was signed
and with her husband she decided to call
the baby hope
and today she says and I quote
peace is a process not an event
everybody's responsible
and change begins with yourself
end of quote
she is so right
I can reassure you
that we the European Union
will continue to do our part
and to accompany you on the path of
peace and prosperity
today
my grandchildren
are toddlers
what Northern Ireland
and the whole island of Ireland will
look like
when they are in their twenties
depends on all of us
but the ultimate Choice lies with you
the people of Northern Ireland
to shape your history
and that of the Next Generation
the gateway to a bright future is open
all you need to do is walk through it
thank you very much